[Music]
let's go to brianna in columbus what's
up brianna
hello
how are we doing
i'm doing pretty good how are you we are
just figuring it out every day right
so what's up absolutely
um okay so my question is
how much should you talk to your spouse
about work
oh
nothing
never are you crazy
what uh what's uh tell me some more
about what you're asking okay so um
about three years ago we moved 12 hours
away from our everything we knew for his
job okay can we stop right here
you're gonna have to let that resentment
go
i don't know what comes after this but
you'll have no peace in your home or in
your marriage and if you've got kids in
your parenting unless you let that piece
go
or y'all move back
is that cool
absolutely you're definitely right about
that um we are moving back in a few
months
can i ask you why are you moving back
it was only supposed to be a temporary
thing um he they opened a new location
needed someone who knew the company to
come and manage it for a little bit so
they kind of got up and going okay and
it turned into a couple of years
yeah it was originally gonna be two to
three years so we're out a little longer
than three years
okay have you hated it the whole time
uh 80 of the time
why did you hate it
i
was very i have a very close family okay
and i
really struggled
figuring out
how to
make connection with other people
that i didn't already know
at least a little bit
or that didn't know me
gotcha
so yeah that was a that was definitely a
struggle for a long time
um and i went to work at the same place
that he worked um because i needed a job
and didn't know where to get a job at
um and we live on the property
oh jeez
so
i most of my life is
revolved around one thing and that is
with the place that he works now i don't
work there at the moment i work
somewhere else
and have
been able to find friends there and
connection there
um but sometimes it feels like my entire
life is consumed
by the place that he works why is it
consumed
um
i
i
worked there for a long time
i started my day there i ended my day
there and even though
you know we come home and it's not you
know we're not clocked in i'm not at
work i
struggle a lot to
turn that off in my mind
and i still have a hard time with that
even though i don't work there anymore
like i have a saying when i get off of
work that i have to tell myself so that
my brain will
transition and i can just go home and be
who i am there and i'm not you know
clocked in anymore i'm not working i'm
not what is it one of the things that
happened what's it the things that
you're
you're plugged into is it like is it the
gossip and like who you know
someone slept with dan again i mean is
it that or is it
are you dialed into the
like the business function and and
how we're like we're making money like
what are you missing
um
for him
or for the place where he works i
think that it's more so that i
just want to make sure that everything's
still okay
why
that seems like an incredible burden to
to carry especially when you can do
nothing about it
i would agree with that um let me let me
back out a little bit
um because i think this is all connected
so follow me on a train of thought here
okay absolutely
um
so you you left
yes
your close-knit family
and there was an awkward period where
you weren't there anymore and you
weren't in the know and you weren't in
the in the figuring it all out right
yeah
and you found yourself
on an island somewhere 12 hours away or
as you say it 12 hours away right so
really far away oh a half of a day away
it's only a day
annie no i won't do that that's 24 hours
so it's not 12.
so you find yourself 12 hours away
and then there's this decision point
there's this moment
i don't know anybody here and i'm
completely disconnected here
i have one of two choices
i can
just go be weird and i can go be awkward
and i can go find people and try to be
awkward with them and be like hey i'm
new to town and this is weird and you
all want to go get
you know sandwiches or do you want to go
get coffee or i'm having a barbecue
y'all are coming to my house and you
bring the weird desserts because this is
what y'all do 12 hours away from
everything i know
and in that process you have no you
don't know the skills you don't know any
of the of the lingo you don't know the
culture
but you're figuring it out along the way
and the key is you're you're stumbling
and tripping and falling
forward with other people
the other decision
is i'm just gonna sit here and watch
netflix and be pissed off for three
years
and i'm gonna get a job and get really
embedded into my little world and if i
pull that same thread over here you went
to work with your husband in the same
exact place which hey put food on the
table gave you something to do probably
wasn't the best thing globally but it is
what it is it happened
and
then you left for whatever reason
probably best for your marriage and all
things
but instead of now making a new place
you put a an anchor into that place
and you're trying to control things that
backwards again
and instead of living in the place that
you are
you're trying to control places that
you've been
see what i'm saying
yeah and so my challenge to you is like
so to answer your question how do you
stop then you just stop
that sounds so ridiculous
um here's what it looks like in real
life in real real life
um
i'm just going to give you a personal
example because i did this yesterday
there's a
i work with university officials behind
closed doors and kind of walk they you
know we talk and help each other through
problems and things and challenges
one i gave it clear
do not do this thing
and that person wouldn't did that thing
and i'm beginning to hear about it
across the country
and
i was with a group of people yesterday
and i was like i'm telling you i said
don't do this thing and while i'm saying
this out loud number one i'm gossiping
about somebody which is completely
stupid it's just to lift me up which is
so lame
and b
i
like
i stop myself it's like why do you care
you don't go to that school your kids
don't go to that school you have no
vested interest like what are you doing
and i literally stopped mid-sentence and
just trailed off the conversation in an
awkward way and luckily i'm so awkward
most of the time nobody did nobody
thought twice about it
here's what it looks like in real time
for you the moment you're like well hey
is so
nope
not gonna do that
and saying to yourself i literally don't
care
and i want you to practice that
and then more importantly i want you to
practice having something else to talk
about something else of interest to you
something else that you're working on or
pretending to get involved in or
practicing you see what i'm saying
yeah
absolutely tell me why that's tell me if
that's hard
i know it is and i know i'm making it
sound so easy but tell me
like
because it is super hard but it's also
really simple
yeah
um
i'm not really i don't know that i know
the answer to that question
um
says that this
i feel like
that i was drowning in an ocean and this
little big tiny boat
came and grabbed me
and now this boat sinking but because it
saved my life the first time i'm still
holding on to it instead of getting on a
different boat gotcha if that makes
sense yes
unpack drowning for me
what does that actually mean was it that
you were lost at sea because you left
everything you knew and came to a new
city in a new state in a new part of the
country
you always say you go with you
and that is true for me when we moved
here i had to face
the things that i needed to take care of
and that i needed to do differently
and
that has been a long
scary process for me that i have never
seen modeled for me awesome um did you
do it so
i did i'm still doing it and i'm never
gonna stop doing it it's been incredible
so a lot of the time it felt like i was
just gonna go all the way under and i
was never gonna climb back out
um
but you did yeah but it did did you do
it with other people
yes
and those times you thought you were
going under
you realized that other people are
holding you up
which is why i'm always so adamant about
people getting to other people you just
described in very clear terms bravery
that's courage
i'm really really proud of you
so
understand this so you go with you
that's like a little saying i throw
around all the time
um i'm gonna try to make a saying out of
what i'm about to say here i'm not gonna
try to make it i'm trying to make a cool
little thing that i could put on the
internets but i don't know i'm not good
at that
um
what's the right way to say this um
just because it hurts doesn't mean it's
wrong
and my guess is you're going to look
back on these three years
where you had to figure out who you were
and what you were made of and the skills
you were missing you've known it for a
long time but you got to stay in a
regular rhythm and routine
and when you're with family a lot they
keep you in your place you know what i
mean
yeah my sister's four years older than
me and my brother's five years younger
than me and we all get together
and we go right back to being older
sister middle middle kid younger brother
right
and when you untether all that
12 hours away
and you do that then
something you have you've known for a
long time and here you are dealing with
it and here's the thing when you go home
people are going to recognize you
yeah and it's going to be real easy to
go back to old brianna
yeah and that's
that's a fear i've been working through
yeah
so let me let me tell you something and
one of the things i think that the
modern mental health community of which
i'm a part of i'm at fault here too
we haven't done a good job
of
let me say this
we have communicated to people that
mental health and wellness is just
getting the right thoughts in the right
order
and if you can just think the right
things in the right order everything is
quote unquote gonna be okay
and so there is an important part to
think about this coming as you're
heading home
and the work you've done
and the new skills you've picked up and
then brianna that now stands six inches
taller than the one who went 12 hours
away right
[Music]
but i want to add something to it that
the the modern mental health community
is left out is you're gonna have to do
different things
you're gonna have to hang out with
different people and maybe even live in
a different part of the town
and you're gonna have to say no to
things
and you're not just gonna go right back
to the same thursday night dinners at
miles house or whatever because that's
the night that you and your husband have
right whatever y'all gonna do
but you're gonna have to create a new
world and live into it and that's gonna
be really insulting to the people who
expect you to come back and be the
brianna that they
have created in their own mind
yeah right i i absolutely agree with
that does your husband is he in support
of you
a million times over
does he love
um brianna 2.0
yeah
absolutely is he scared about you going
back to being you when you get home
um
i would think that would be a little bit
of a fear for him um have you asked him
he would
i don't think i've asked him that way
ask him that way
okay
because my guess is it's not just it's
just a little fear i bet it's a big one
and it would be really fun exercise for
y'all
to create a world to like engineer a new
environment moving forward and say
here's the magic question who are we
going to be
the day we land back at home
who are we going to be
and when we say who we're going to be
we're going to be fun we're going to be
spontaneous we're going to be laughing
we're going to keep our
our weekly movie nights we're going to
keep our
random uh thanksgiving full of misfits
we're we're gonna keep these these parts
of ourselves and that's gonna inform the
things that you're not gonna do
the phone is still getting put away at
eight o'clock at night so i'm not
responding to every family member
emergency texts because they're not all
emergencies and i don't want to right
i'm going to begin to create this world
and then i'm going to live into it it's
going to be fantastic
so hear me say i'm so proud of you
recreate this world together that you're
going home to
to answer your original original
question about how much should we talk
about work every couple's different i've
learned that the
less the better
and in my house we set some pretty
strong boundaries and so i will say
things like can i talk about a thing
that happened at work today and my wife
will say do you want a solution you want
me just to listen
and i will say i need to need you to
listen and she'll say great go for it
um by setting up the setting up the
conversation it keeps her from just
becoming my trash bin and me coming home
and just dumping crap on her all day
long every day so i structure the
conversations like i want to tell you
something about work
normally i say i'm struggling with
feeling like i'm not doing anything
worth the crap or i'm struggling with a
hard conversation i have to have it work
that's less about work and that's about
me and she wants to hear about that
she does not want to hear about the
gossip and i don't want to talk about it
she doesn't want to hear about what's
the what's the you know the
i don't know the
profit report she don't hear about that
she wants to know if her paycheck is
going to change right
but i think going home and using work as
a living soap opera to prop up two
people having a conversation with one
another is a terrible terrible way to
live
create your own life
with your own joys and your own hard
stuff
and talk about those things
and if you leave a job
leave it all the way
leave it all the way thank you so much
for your bravery brian i'm proud of you
i'm really proud of you i can't wait to
see what happens next
you